won that game so now it's time for
revenge for the world champion yeah
david is that what it is about for
magnus carlsen in this game revenge
against eric anderson it's definitely
about revenge magnus as we mentioned he
bears grudges he remembers every defeat
he's ever
been inflicted on and he wants to win
against that opponent to show who is the
boss and last time in the air things
masters we actually saw uh magnus again
with white there he opened with his
king's pawn one e4 he's gone away from
that and now he's opened with the
english opening
and uh okay eric maybe not expecting
this how will he react in the opening
eric
great player of course to great in the
air things masters but he is known to
suffer from time trouble he's very slow
in certain positions
and maybe magnus just wants to give him
a lot of choice at this early stage
uh eric deciding upon what to play and
just occupying the center with the pawn
this is what we call the four knights
variation and magnus just again pushing
a pawn to fiance his bishop oh wow that
is very nice
new to me i think at this level to see
those four nights out there
yeah um there are various different
types of four nights openings there's
one in king's pawn openings um this is
one of them but yeah it's it's not
necessarily the most common uh variation
and that's why magnus has chosen it i
think he just wants eric to be thinking
for himself at an early stage if we
rewind one month when eric beat magnus
that was a really theoretical battle i
think eric was able to get the first 15
20 moves down on the board almost
instantly and later he was able to
calculate his way to trick magnus and
eventually win the game so magnus just
may be learning from that defeat he's
trying a different strategy here they
kind of look like you know like four
like pillars
in the entrance into the position yeah
and oh one of them's moved okay
unfortunately
we do see a trade of horns and now
after this white's going to castle
black's going to get his bishop out he's
going to do the same and
um yeah we call this the reverse dragon
there's lots of different names it's a
cool game already come on exactly this
is actually a sicilian defense now just
with reverse colors and it would be the
dragon variation of the sicilian i'm not
sure why it's called the dragon maybe
because it breathes fire but
um either way this is still well known
theoretically i remember a win by magnus
carlsen in 2009 against vladimir kramnik
in this opening he's got fond memories
so uh yeah he's just hoping to outplay
eric so just the name of the opening is
uh the reversed dragons the reverse so
i'm this is the opening that i'm gonna
study i love it already super cool i
used to play this yeah
i used to play this variation actually
but first but for blitz games i was
moving my knight to not to be to
well this side to the queen side to b6
but i was moving it to e7 let's say
where the bishop is standing now so a
different branch maybe yes
it had some tricks there and was like i
played it quite successfully uh in in
blitz games you know even i remember
against motlov
some good funny memories i was also just
seriously impressed by david blocking
out a game from over 13 years ago and
saying hey this is between magnus
carlson and
valdemar kramnik and check my database
lo and behold 2009 london classic
yeah i mean i know i sound impressive
but i was sitting next to them
because you were playing i was playing
in those days okay so you were playing
and you remember the game going on next
to you
not impressive at all david
that's only because i think maybe it was
my best ever result i came third in the
tournament behind carlson and france ah
nice um yeah those were the glory days
you have you do have quite a few good
results in london yeah this is true yeah
yeah i was also impressed today when you
said then game number six of the match
yeah some habits i think you you take
them also but i think so i remember game
sixes because we talked a lot about game
six that's when the drama starts to
happen in the world championship matches
yeah historically i think there's been a
kind of disproportionate number of
decisive results right in game six if
you go back to the 19th century already
many uh world championship matches
decided
uh yeah by those kind of critical
moments in the middle of the match so
it was a pity i just left dubai at this
moment in the sixth game
this and i was given a short interview
to chess 24 um with us killed and uh and
actually um
they asked my opinion and they said it's
going to be at the 5 6 game should be
one of the most important games of the
match
and then i like oh it was such a pity
it changed the whole momentum of the
match i mean that was quite interesting
because before that i think david and
myself had both had
requests from the bbc and newsnight to
kind of appear on their shows and
discuss how compu computers were just
ruining the game and their players were
playing too perfectly and there was just
no margin for actual chats and for human
error
and lo and behold
game six happy
and the gates opened and uh we saw
napoli actually collapse and actually we
saw magnus uh uh use a very human
approach to avoid all this computer
preparation so everything that you know
had been said before
well
he is known for that right magnus
carlsen the human approach to the game
exactly um he's i think one of the
biggest students of the game he studied
all the former world champions he would
have been aware that game six is kind of
a historical match and just in terms of
general chess style as well he picks up
little tips here and there he knows how
to put psychological pressure on his
opponents and
okay i mean while getting back to this
game it has differed from that carlson
against kramnik game that i mentioned
earlier
but white has started pushing pawns
trying to gain space on the queen side
on this left side of the board
black just organizing his pieces it
looks like black's been retreating a bit
especially the black dark squad bishop
going back next to his king but this is
very common uh type of technique and now
magnus jumped forward with the white
bishop attacking the white attacking the
black queen uh we saw that blocked and
it's really interesting magnus actually
just gave up a move with this bishop
maneuver he will jump forward allow
black to gain time by blocking and then
retreated he's hoping that the black
king is vulnerable on this light square
diagonal if we look at the white at the
black king on the white squares some
loose uh
some possibility maybe of an attack
later in the game so okay eric meanwhile
reacting very quickly pushing a pawn
trying to force white to commit on this
queen side do you step forward with mike
uh if you're magnus do you trade a set
of pawns i'm expecting to see him step
forward with the pawn here but then
eric's going to jump into the center
with a black knight and this is still
very thematic both players clearly have
studied something similar to this before
and i just wanted to mention something
that uh magnus's bishop maneuver
actually attacking the queen provoking
that pawn weakness
has been played before wasn't the most
popular line actually and this is
something that we've seen from magnus
time and time again he goes into these
main lines and then picks a sideline and
takes his opponent into these
these kind of unfamiliar territories
yeah he did this in the world
championship match right he went into
the main lines but then chose the fifth
most popular move so it's unlikely the
opponent would have studied that then
the next game he'll choose the fourth
most popular move and he just confuses
his opponents because they've studied
something very similar but not exactly
that and that's how he's able to kind of
stay unpredictable
just dancing around in the opening so
um earlier we had this question right
like
should you focus on studying the
openings but there are special kind of
special time consuming or time efficient
ways sorry uh to study the openings
where you can surprise your opponents
and it can be really effective meanwhile
though eric doing a great job of staying
up on the clock because that has been
his achilles heel
his only weakness really in the athens
masters last month 15 minutes left on
the clock and we see eric sitting there
with his uh sweater with the chest bra
logo he has a known a big big chest
streamer as most of you probably know
and a move two moves yeah wow really
committal as well from magnus carlsen so
he's traded off white's dark squared
bishop which tends to be quite a good
piece actually in these positions
he's traded off for a night but look at
black's pawns over there on the b file
black has two double pawns over there
and uh magnus is gonna hope he's gonna
play the long game he's gonna hope
that's a strategic weakness later on but
black does have the bishop pair so this
is really really
complex now i'm not sure who i prefer in
these types of positions
white has a great light square bishop to
compensate for
maybe his lack of fight on the dark
squares later on but then again
if black can get organized if black can
get all his pieces off the back rank at
some point then eric will be happy and
eric's bobbing his head he looks
confident yeah
all right well
and he has a lot of time on the clock
now are you a big fan of chess streaming
anastasia and you watch it a lot i don't
i don't watch it a lot but of course i'm
following from time to time yeah of
course i i know the names of the
most famous streamers yes i also have my
twitch account but i must say that i'm a
bit lazy
person
and so i appear from time to time for
commentaries on different websites uh
and you know also sometimes traveling to
for chess events so but streaming yes
it's it's cool and we all know that eric
hanson is a really popular and good
streamer these days and um still he's
able to to fight on on the very decent
level which is great yeah isn't that
impressive
it's basically a full-time job for him
right to be a chess streamer to be here
with the best players in the world
competing at the very top yes i i agree
and when i think of chess bar i'm always
reminded of the time when i first moved
into my house and we didn't have any
internet so my husband sorted out some
kind of i don't know satellite okay
broadband where we had a fixed capacity
and he thought that he'd bought a lot
except i
went on chat
and i watched their streams
and i think two days later my husband
was like well hang on a second
more interesting more internet what
happened there i was like oh the
streaming take up that much internet and
he goes okay yeah so
i tell this story to eric and he goes
yeah sorry sorry i ate up your ball back
you stopped watching yeah
i did it was very enjoyable
meanwhile we've seen a huge move by
magnus carson because he sacrificed a
pawn and it's not 100 clear what his
plan is if eric
doesn't trust him and takes it but okay
eric did not call the bluff uh magnus i
think he had a special idea up his
sleeve and i just have to show this
because it's so beautiful
here in this position magnus has just
brought his knight back actually
blocking the queen's connection to this
pawn in front of it and now black could
have got greedy and could have captured
this pawn and i was trying to work out
there just uh while you were discussing
chester i was trying to work out what
the idea was
maybe the idea is actually to bring the
white knight forward to this square and
black's queen actually has a selection
of knights to capture here if we see a
trade of queens yes white's a pawn down
but white is doing well because there
are weaknesses to attack but no matter
which knight the black queen captured it
would have got trapped if you take this
knight the black queen is trapped here
there's no escape squares and you lose
the queen if you took the other knight
then suddenly a fork and a double attack
this is just beautiful i've near nearly
never seen this type of pattern before
in my life so magnus carlson there
setting a trap but eric didn't fall into
it i'm just curious whether eric saw it
whether he uh just trusted magnus and uh
didn't even want to calculate didn't
even want to waste time working out the
consequences there instead he brought
his rook across and white's knight has
indeed jumped over and just to kind of
sum up the position here remember white
has a better pawn structure black's
pawns here are doubled they're ugly
they're weak but black has the bishop
pair so these two bishops are the kind
of the soul of black's position if black
can develop these pieces for example the
bishop coming out now and maybe even
developing his bishop out later in the
game this guy out come out to a decent
square if he can do that eric's doing
well but if not magnus has weaknesses to
probate and he loves those types of
things
okay the bishop has indeed come out to
cover the light squares around the black
king that's a good start
so it's all about the bishops and
whether white can prove these are
weaknesses magnus is going for them he's
brought his knight to the side of the
board
double attack now against this pawn
and it's just a really complex
positional strategic fight eric dropping
back with his knight he's
counter-attacking against the white
pawns now and uh eric i've nev never
seen him play this fast i must admit
this is a clear strategy from him he's
clearly learned his lesson from the last
tournament where time did eventually see
him uh time struggles eventually saw him
eliminated in the quarterfinals
i wonder was it possible to take this
knight on which was
actually
[Music]
threatening the pawn on b6 i mean
instead of moving the knight yeah
i'm not sure
um yeah i think it would have been
possible for black's light squad bishop
to go and capture a night but maybe he
was just worried about heading towards
an end game and magnus is a specialist
there
eric maybe just trying to keep more
tension in the position
i mean i say i'm impressed that he's
playing so fast i'm just surprised
because some huge decisions for him as
you mentioned anastasia he had options
many options on every turn but eric is
just ramping up the speed yeah
and uh now when it comes to eric
increasing his pace i'm kind of reminded
of an article that i think i read in the
newer chat magazine where he talks about
his experiences in his debut the u.s aim
chess rapid last season and there he
just said that he was too slow and he
got all these promising positions and he
just kept squandering them with one move
blunders and so he promised himself in
the second debut that
in the air things masters he was not
going to be doing that but he still
found himself in time trouble and so i
think now it's like okay
i'm going to learn my lesson and i'm
going to play as confidently as i can
yeah it must have been a confidence
boost for him to do so well in the last
tournament beating magnus and getting
through to the knockouts um okay
meanwhile a set of pawns have been
exchanged on this left side of the board
on the queen side
and uh in general if we just stop
calculating this should favor black
because black has traded off a very
strong white pawn for one of black's
doubled pawns but then again black's
knight is undefended temporarily white's
knights look very nice
you can imagine the white queen jumping
out gaining a bit of time okay she has
done this attacking the black knight and
the pawn next to it
so it's become a bit more concrete it is
about calculation now and
i know eric has played fast and we've
been praising him for it but he needs to
slow down around now because things are
getting a bit critical if you're too
passive with black you might just lose a
pawn and not get any compensation for it
so now is the time now it's a really
critical moment invest three or four
minutes try and work out what's
happening over the next few moves
and that's a great advice actually from
you david you know it's very important
to feel the moment when you really need
to spend time i think many players use i
mean the internet also used to play one
minute games like three minutes games
and
like nobody's used to think properly
about something which is really
important i mean we have some critical
moments in every game and it's really
important to go through different
variations and find the best way uh how
to continue so of course such a good
player as eric hanson knows that knows
it and
he will definitely spend some time
but
i mean it can it i mean this is very
time management is a very important
skill skill yeah yes definitely
yeah no i was just going to say that i
actually checked the computer to see
whether you know
eric was actually walking a tightrope
and he is there's actually only one good
night move and that's actually to go
forward with the night to jump into
white's heart exactly wow that's brief
that is brave because my instinct was
actually just to step backwards with the
white with the black knight challenged
its counterpart same um
so the most natural move may be going
back with the black knight at least the
safest most logical move is a mistake it
is a mistake wow okay
and yeah actually you mentioned that
time management there anastasia and
i think especially for streamers that's
why it's so impressive that eric's done
well uh when he's come back to longer
forms of chess and against the best in
the world because streamers mostly play
blitz they mostly play bullet um it's
hard to get a rhythm once you have more
time
to think and
yeah he's been mightily impressive and i
think that's why okay i joke about my
time management lots of people joke
about it but i do spend a lot of time in
order to kind of formulate a long-term
plan is i try to pick the critical
moments and that's what the top players
do from practice from learning kind of
studying they realize when to spend
their time i have a question for you
dave because i was uh watching uh your
games
and you and nils would often settle into
very long things
and i have to ask how did you maintain
your concentration because you know
how did you kind of not spend like five
minutes and then your brain goes how
about this tune or something how did you
just focus
did you have any tips there i'm not sure
i was that focused
i mean most the time i was able to think
and
most of the time my moves were okay
after those long things but there was
one case where i spent nearly 40 minutes
and i came up with the wrong plan and i
kind of didn't trust my first instincts
so um there are pros and cons definitely
but i guess it helped that we were in
this grand library i had this amazing
venue and there was literally nothing
else apart from a chessboard so you had
to focus and
i also make a rule of never listening to
music before games or on the day of
games just because i don't want anything
in my head apart from the chess
and do you structure your thoughts like
for instance first of all you start off
with a bigger picture and then you're
like okay these are the moves i need to
calculate or does your mind oh that's
like my mind it's a bit chaotic
jumps here and then suddenly there might
be this eureka moment where i'm like
woohoo hang on a second there's this
i must admit before i started commentary
work it was just a mess in my head
but uh ever since i started commentating
i do occasionally take a step back and
talk to myself and actually especially
when i'm in time trouble i take a step
back and thinking i think okay my
opponent is going to play this this or
this
okay i have a force move against this
one i don't have to worry about that one
i have a force move here this one i need
to calculate so i'll focus on this one
and it's just it's easiest to structure
now i can take a step back
but uh yeah instincts are rusty but i
think the logical thinking is improved
so
nice yeah yeah if you want to improve in
chess you have to become a commentator
now i know the trick
that's why we're so good
yeah
and
if you have any questions any comments
uh send us your selfies you know just
get enthusiastic about the actual chess
that's happening then don't forget you
can tweet us using the hashtag
oh chess champs oh yeah i needed to
catch my breath
in a bit of a long sentence and uh yeah
we will try and feature them on the show
definitely hashtag chess champs on
twitter the way to reach us and also the
auction for david's chest high only 40
minutes left now exactly 40 minutes to
go to make your bid for
the lucky chest high and the current bid
450 dollars oh
that's impressive
almost speechless
thank you yeah it's touching isn't it
that uh
people support the show that much that
they're able and willing to buy a chest
higher yeah by the chess auctions and
also to support the cause and it really
is like you were mentioning anastasia
you know that everyone is coming
together helping out
and being part of this big wonderful
community
absolutely
this
tournament is all about uh charity cup
and donating to unicef who is
doing life-saving work in and around
ukraine for the children and their
families in need there so uh yeah keep
donating we're so much appreciating
every single dollar you're contributing
with and we're also allowing ourselves
to be entertained by the chess in this
tournament magnus carlsen out for
revenge against eric hansen here eric
for the very first time in his life was
able to win against magnus carlsen in a
tournament in the air things masters i
have to say magnus is looking uh focused
he is not going to lose this game yeah
he's looking confident as well just body
language he thinks okay white has
control remember white has a couple of
threats white is hitting the black
knight with the white queen but the
white queen is also attacking the pawn
in front of it and also as ivanka
revealed there's only really one move
for black to stay in this game to keep
things uh balanced and it's not an easy
one it's not an obvious one eric's done
the right thing he's paused now he's
realized it is a critical moment that uh
kind of the path is narrowed the stakes
are higher than ever
she finds the best move though
so that's yeah i mean that's mightily
impressive he paused at the right moment
and the whole idea is if white's queen
went up and grabbed a pawn black's queen
would have been able to come down and
take a pawn as well so white's queen was
forced to retreat and now the black
knight also stepping back but the black
knight it's done a bit of a dance it's
found it's safe it's found itself on a
safe square just offering some exchanges
and yeah okay white has an advantage
here according to the evaluation bar but
it's not easy at least for magnus and
eric's done a good job of staying in the
game
and okay magnus just i just want to
point out really nice move improving the
white rooks they were doing nothing and
now he's defending his knights with his
rooks all of the pieces entering the
action and okay
surprised by eric hansen just taking the
time out to shuffle his king to the
corner maybe he'd seen this position in
advance actually when he was having that
longer think a few moves ago the black
king much safer on a dark square in the
corner but then again
long term it could get trapped there
there could be some background checks
uh it is also costing one valuable move
so pros and cons to that yeah and i'm
also thinking
should the game reach an end game which
is what magnus is famous for that king
in the corner that was going to take a
bit of a time and journey to get back
into the game
i was also thinking maybe he is he just
gives a chance for the bishop to go to
the same square where the king was
before maybe
in some situations maybe this idea also
he had in mind if he would will try to
find some useful moves maybe this move
would be one of them because magnus
improves his position and black has to
do something um so maybe he can remove
his bishop
at certain point
yeah maybe we can show this idea uh
anastasia i've just because uh also
um i must admit in that match that we've
been talking about quite a lot today uh
as black i planted my bishop on the g8
square the first time i did it because
it was the only move and then a few
games later i did it just because i
thought it would be funny to play the
same move i played a few moves ago and
it was a mistake so um yeah as you
mentioned erica saw your games and maybe
it was inspired
you shouldn't be inspired by this bishop
retreat uh for example one thing magnus
could do here i'm actually expecting him
maybe to make an exchange but one thing
he could do when in doubt remember pick
up a pawn push it forward
and black's bishop could actually step
back and the reason this is actually
quite attractive for black is because
this king is super safe now and yes it's
a retreating move but bishops are long
range pieces and the bishop still has
influence on this diagonal but it also
gets out of the way of the black rook on
this line it keeps the king nice and
safe and
yeah maybe one idea behind his move um
if we go back i mentioned i'm expecting
magnus to make a trade i think it would
take extraordinary self-control to just
push a pawn and just kind of maintain
the status quo
but i'm expecting just knight takes
night and a similar idea that zhu when
jun used in the previous game lifting
the white rook up the board to the fifth
rank
slightly into the black half of the
board but also eyeing up weaknesses
hitting this pawn also trying to force
black to make a decision with this
bishop now it's attacked twice by the
rook and bishop and if we see a trade we
will see what we call a good night
against a bad bishop and this is a bad
bishop because a lot of its pawns are
dark squares as well especially its
central pawns so it's actually going to
get blocked in by its own pawns
and it's also got no targets whereas
this is a really good night because how
is black ever going to remove it um
it's also got targets so
yeah this does look slightly in white's
favor still bishops are good defenders
even the worst bishop even this one
likes to remind me and it okay magnus i
joked about it but he's played the move
that we've seen already in every game
today he's played h4 picked up this pawn
and
he's given his king some breathing space
instructive but also just hinting to
eric that this pawn might destabilize
the black key position later in the game
okay magnus has indeed just maintained
the status quo i said this would take
extraordinary self-control magnus is
that type of player super patient just
doing nothing but in a useful way and uh
that's one skill that the top players
really have yeah it's really hard to to
have such a skill just to stay
peaceful and don't make your position
worse than it is now
is it a brave move by magnus
yeah um in a way he's not really
weakened himself but at the same time
showing that maybe he can do something
later exactly he's just putting the fear
of ghosts into the opponent in a way so
now at the back of his mind eric always
has to just wonder about that white
h-pawn pushing up the board um and
personally as someone who plays a lot of
blitz and a lot of bullet chess online
it's so annoying when my opponent just
pushes the pawn and kind of leaves it
there just hanging
every move i have to spend half a second
thinking is that porn going to continue
advancing
and uh yeah just something for eric
the psychology of chess i know and i
also it's also this poor move doesn't
come with too much risk because look at
that chain of pawns
you want your pawns to be in chains and
uh
that sounded a bit strange but anyway
rick
is lined up with his queen and now
there's a threat in the air
eric is threatening to play queen takes
born yeah and again really calm by eric
a nice move there i think magnus was
maybe a bit too relaxed because if you
look at the white knight it looks like
that white knight is dominating the
black rooks the black rocks can't use
the open c file because that white
knight is so strong but the black rook
now with its queen
it's eyeing up the only real weak born
in white's position in the center there
on the d-file and
how do you defend that pawn with white
it's not actually easy the white rook in
the corner wants to slide across and
defend it but then there's another
weakness that white rook in the corner
is guarding another pawn
maybe eric's caught magnus a bit off
guard here magnus is a bit off balance
he wants this position but with another
move maybe his h-pawn move was just a
bit too
too much of a luxury maybe a4 was better
you know at least to remove this a3 pawn
from um um being attached
yeah suddenly
magnus maybe he has to take a timeout
with the white bishop okay he puts it in
the center of the board that is
provocative i thought he maybe would
drop it back next to his king keep it
safe
but now what happens if eric pushes a
pawn to kick that bishop away that's a
good question
he plays really actively
yeah i guess
interesting after i fight what he'll do
i think he's going to block the default
with his bishop
but magnus he's trying to force eric to
push this pawn forward he actually gave
up a move earlier to let eric push the f
pawn forward for free now he's trying to
do it again but eric pushes this pawn
look at the black king that's a bit
loose that is totally loose but i'm
looking at that paw move and i'm
thinking this is just a waving a red
flag to push
the harry one square forward
and to soften up the king side that that
extra bit because uh as david pointed
out white has a really nice response to
black attacking the bishop with his pawn
yeah so if black had attacked the bishop
the white knight the white bishop sorry
would have jumped into the middle of the
board and i still think this was maybe
the lesser evil black could have traded
a set here and at least now black has
kicked the white knight away so the
black rooks can start to get active but
instead pushing this pawn the reason i
don't like this is because it is rapid
chess and again it's the psychology uh
it's that word psychology that kai
mentioned this king now is slightly
looser uh just because you have pushed
pawns in front of your king and magnus
has a timeout maybe it's time for to
just combine all the plans we've been
discussing anastasia mentioned this pawn
being loose and a bit of a target on
this diagonal maybe it's time to push
this up one square put everything on
white squares so that the black dark
square bishop has nothing to
hit on and uh yeah now i think white is
safe again if pawn pushes forward then
you just block this file for the black
queen and black rook it's just really
frustrating for black again we might see
a situation with good knight against a
bishop that's not that great
and yeah just a small advantage for
magnus but it could be as the evaluation
bar shows it could be the type of
advantage that grows move by move now
so i feel eric's last move a pawn push
weakening and just a bit too slow
he needed to be a bit more concrete a
bit more aggressive maybe attacking the
opponent's bishop
and magnus okay meanwhile bringing his
queen to the side of the board it has
been there already yeah surprising it's
been there already as you mentioned
it was here five six moves ago and at
least he's going for a pawn
uh really surprising i think eric now
has to push this pawn forward otherwise
he's just too passive he's too late look
at all his pieces on the back rank you
need to activate somehow uh you need to
just start getting aggressive and hit
this bishop kick it away from its dream
square in the middle of the board yeah
and uh earlier you mentioned the word
psychology and i'm just gonna ask you
daniel nolan's questions who asks us do
chess players at the top level ever get
overconfident when playing players of
lower ratings
yes
normally they're good enough to control
positions but i've been there myself
i've underestimated
players lower rated if they're a couple
of hundred points lower i just sometimes
think okay if i'm if everything's okay
or everything's
on a normal day i would beat them but
then
there's no such thing as a weak player
nowadays everyone's so good
so i've taken risks and they have
backfired
i know that some top players
occasionally in the first round of open
tournaments it's normally top half plays
bottom half you see surprises from time
to time
and
you know you end up playing moves that
you wouldn't normally play just because
you underestimate the opponent yeah i
have a confession to make um
i'm gonna condition my answer and say
i'm ageist
[Laughter]
so if my opponent is younger than me
like significantly younger like teenager
then i will say
no i don't i i'm never
because
overconfident
so fast they're fresh when they're older
than me and to say if i'm going to say
60s
50s and 60
totally
totally overconfident i think there's no
way that they can beat me and i take big
risks
so i mean it's really the wrong approach
actually too but uh yeah and i fall and
foul of this many times
definitely that's a good approach
because when you see the smoke small kid
i mean or young boy yeah or girl sitting
in front of you you should worry a
little bit you know you never know and
the rating sometimes doesn't really show
the strengths of of young
let's say generation we can see here
pragnanda who is only 16 and he is has
similar rating with his top players so
we shouldn't underestimate
just players only because they're
younger actually it goes the other way
around
absolutely now but how big of a
difference is a hundred rating points
for example here we have magnus on a
2800 kind of rating we do have
a few players on 2500 rating i mean how
in 10 games how many times will magnus
win against 2 500 rated players yeah
that's a good question actually uh
because the fee day ratings they have
specific percentage scores that you're
expected against an average
opponent that's how you calculate
ratings for example um
in my recent match against nils we
basically have the same rating so we're
expected 50 against each other if i win
a game i get kind of five rating points
because i get kind of 0.5 more
and magnus against the 2500 player i
guess he'd be expected
80 something percent wow yeah so if he
draws he would lose three or four rating
points um but if he wins he only gains
one or two
so um there's if you i think you can
probably see on fido uh website all
these calculations there's always a
specific expectant
expected score yeah i had a bit of a
thought experiment the other day where i
was thinking if someone say let's say
rated 1800 which is a reasonably strong
player played against say someone of
david's level 2700
and they played a 100 game match and
assuming that they have the same kind of
endurance level
could
that yeah that 1800 score
a point yeah like a half a point as soon
as they had scored a half point then the
1800 would lose it would win
do you think that's possible was that
really interesting yeah anyway make it
happen as an experiment sometimes
the 100 game match is a bit much
we do i oh i have a dilemma actually
following up on that but just uh this
move first david yeah it's actually the
two moves we expected so um i mentioned
eric had to uh had to just push pawns
forward he had to take risks because
sitting still sits being passive
never helps interests especially when
you're defending um and magnus met that
attack on his bishop met that pawn push
by blocking the defile with his bishop
okay so still very very tense and the
clocks are ticking down so
excitement is guaranteed in this one i
think all right a draw still far far um
well it's the most unlikely result i
reckon here
okay trader bishops and it's that strong
night in the middle of the ward against
that black bishop which doesn't look
good right now but could come to life
later all right i'll hurry up to take my
dilemma then because i heard this one
on norwegian radio a few years ago would
you
rather be in prison for 10 years or be
in prison until you have beaten magnus
carlsen in a game of chess
i'm always optimistic so i'm like i'm
going to practice every day one time i
must be able to beat him
i understand that's not realistic how
much of a rating would you need to have
to answer that you would stay in prison
until you have beaten magnus carlsen in
chess and you play one game per day one
game per day
i mean uh honestly what would you take
10 years in prison or
staying in prison until you have won one
game against magnus maybe 10 years would
be
for you would be able to right i mean
david still has chances in ioanka too
but there would be 365 games of chess
and you would you would
get
exactly all you do you're in prison all
you do is play chess practice chess so
you'd have 3
650 games
in those 10 years to try and win one yep
yes i mean david you take questions
definitely
the other thing is that maybe you are
ready to stay in the prison in order
just to play so many games with magnus
maybe he doesn't want
that is the answer of a chess player
maybe at one point also he will just
lose the game in order to stop this
challenge
that's creative answers thinking outside
the box okay well uh you said this game
is definitely heating up david what's
happening yeah i think it was heating up
a bit too much for magnus carlson's
liking so he's trying to get the queens
off he's trying to head for his favorite
end game
and uh yeah the white queen's sliding
across defending her knight defending
her rook if the black queen trades white
would recapture and i still think white
has the better chances because white's
minor piece is better the knight
superior to the bishop
eric though allowing the queen exchange
but he's trying to make it happen on his
terms and
right now there is a trap if white's
queen captures the black queen this will
be recaptured by pawn maybe we can show
this
and that would actually end badly for
magnus so eric here rather than playing
queen takes queen and where this pawn
supports everything supports especially
the knight in the middle of the board
this would be maybe okay for black but
still slightly better for white eric
instead offering the queen trade but
setting a trap and this is one thing for
everyone at home to remember don't
necessarily go for the trade unless it
really helps you unless you can do it on
your terms gaining time setting traps
because now after pawn recaptures this
is a double attack a fork so magnus
can't actually take the queens off yet
he needs to find a clever way to do that
i'm wondering what he does here i mean
he could
maybe just move the queen away from the
attack maybe you could move the knight
forward
i don't know it feels a bit loose it
feels like black's rooks are really
coming to life uh for example after a
trade here the black brick will just
move out the way not sure where and at
least black has some active pieces later
in the game so i like what eric's doing
i think he's uh really
uh really dealing well with the pressure
on his position this is the current
position magnus cannot trade queens
magnus has to find something else but
look at the clock times as well one
minute okay he does go for that move i
feel maybe the safest move in the
position bringing his knight to the side
and hitting this black rook yeah i i
have to say um i didn't see a good
alternative actually magnus i think this
is the best chance that he has and i
have to say that i really do like the
way that eric has been handling this
position with a lot a lot of grit and
resilience
yeah i think maybe now is the time to
trade queens i don't really see what
else if you move the rook uh that is
attacked as black then suddenly you have
to worry about these pawns falling at
some point white can't take them yet but
some attacks here white can maybe now
dodge the trade of queens
and i don't think that helps too much
for black so i think maybe just take the
queens off the board for example pawn
takes and then just move the rook you
can even challenge white's rook and
suddenly magnus's advantage is not so
great because the knight's no longer
on its ideal square in the middle
and also we mentioned this earlier a
long long time ago long term this pawn
is actually on a dart square so black's
bishop not as bad as it looks it does
have one target in the position later
i was just thinking that when i was
looking at this ending and i was
thinking i bet magnus is thinking why
didn't i not just move my a pawn push
alice one square hover on a light square
the end
yeah but actually it's not a good idea
to think about what happened in the game
while the game is still not over you
know that's another story of course it's
very hard to be organized and not to let
your thoughts go and back and think why
didn't do this move or that move this is
what happens to anybody i think but one
i think tip for our spectators for our
followers that it's good to finish the
game and only after that to start
thinking what did you do wrong yeah
exactly and we always see the players
analyze the games as soon as they finish
but during the games especially someone
like magnus he's good at just forgetting
and just living in the moment yeah so
yes
it's the only moment when it's good to
forget things actually right just forget
everything until the game is over yeah
no regrets huh so everybody says that
chess players need to have a good memory
so sometimes it's the other way around
you should also be able to forget things
selective memory okay meanwhile the
position we actually predicted did arise
the queens got exchanged to blacks rook
came to the fifth rank actually
defending everything black's bishop also
um
protecting that rook and magnus just
teaming up his rooks together
and eric now has a choice does he trade
those rooks again he's got to decide
whether it's on his terms he does
allowing white to look into the game i
felt that was a bit too accommodating
actually because the only white benefit
benefited from that trade i think it
would have been much better to activate
the other rook
yep
and now black's bishop does have an
opportunity to go and take that pawn it
has happened we highlighted that pawn as
a weakness but black's pawn falls as
well so still level material but double
attack white's rook hitting the bishop
of course first but also the pawn the
black pawn in the center of the board
still eric has some problems to deal
with look at the time it's all 17
seconds oh wow
no one realized talking about time
trouble less than 20 minutes left in the
auction for david's chest high less than
20 minutes the current bid 500 so head
into
cctauction.com and make your bid all
right time travel for eric hansen as
well time trouble and that's when
mistakes happen and already we see the
evaluation bar shoot off to white side
black's bishop now is passive it's gone
to a bad square
that bishop can be hit by the white rook
by the white pawn it does feel like
magnus now has a couple of moves to
create pressure before black is able to
get organized
what do we think is there a way to win a
pawn here for white can white's rook go
up the board to try and gobble up a pawn
again it all comes back to that move 20
moves ago black's king in the corner
just looks like a terrible piece in an
end game and uh somehow black's pawns in
the centre of the board also a bit loose
we talk about advancing pawns sometimes
they can be great but you do leave
weaknesses behind and even in end games
now these pawns don't necessarily defend
each other and magnus going after
black's b pawn
okay we're actually going to see a
similar scenario to the game between zhu
and june and leighton j black has given
up a pawn but he's going to try and seek
solace in a rook end game
you have to get rid of that white knight
over the next couple of moves that white
knight cannot be allowed to survive
because then it will help white's extra
sea pawn forward
so white's a pawn up can magnus convert
it zhu and jun didn't manage to convert
her extra c pawn in the last round
and uh we'll see if magnus will be able
to yeah but magnus has a much better
version of it because um his rook can
perhaps cut off the black king
and i think eric is choosing a different
he's maybe choosing to keep the rook
i mean take the rooks off and keep the
minor pieces on which i'm not sure about
actually okay this is all about timing
because if black's king can get across
fast enough the white knight is almost
trapped and the black king can even go
for white's extra pawn the white extra
pawn blockaded by black's bishop but if
the white knight is able to destabilize
that black bishop if the white king can
get in if the white pawn can push it's
just going to be game over so okay
really interesting maybe eric's
calculated this maybe he's okay
but
i does feel like if magnus is accurate
there must be something
but the but the white knight has one
safe escape route it can relocate itself
to i was going to say the c6 square and
get out via the a-line but he's chosen a
different way yeah so he hit the black
bishop and the black pawn in the middle
of the board at least now the white
knight very minimum as you mentioned
ivanka it does have an escape route it
can jump back to the b6 square and then
back towards the center
but
okay i would be slightly reluctant to
allow black's pawns all onto light
squares as well because if you look at
the king side the right side of the
board white's pawns are all on dark
squares that will mean the white king is
tied down later if the black bishop
tries to sneak in and attack those pawns
i think you have to maybe try and push
some pawns to light squares at some
point
but magnus okay
this is his uh home territory the end
game right and uh it would be a surprise
if he doesn't win this one somehow that
being said eric
fighting fighting hard yes and actually
if he pushes his pawn forward maybe the
king can come closer at this moment yes
yeah so if the black e pawn can push
forward
uh i mean if if white pushes
okay
now yeah that's the point maybe the king
yeah yeah after
so now he choose to move his king but
otherwise c5 would probably lose a pawn
yeah
okay so white didn't take the risk of
pushing the extra pawn forward because
it might become weak as you mentioned
instead trying to activate the white
king but now i'm expecting eric to lock
things down there we go and the pawn
structure on the king's side now
actually maybe favors black
just because white's pawns
are always going to be targets for the
black bishop
suddenly it feels to me like eric's made
some progress and magnus hasn't really
magnus has lost a lot of time with his
knight
and i like what eric's doing you know
he's centralizing the bishop but even
more importantly he's getting ready to
run with the king to the c5 square and
start looking up at the c4 pawn so this
is why magnus plays
a crafty move you know puts his knight
on the edge of the board he says no
you're not going to go for that plan
but it's not the most active night i've
ever seen white's knight is definitely
not the most centralized not the most
happy
but white's king
is slowly going to snake its way over to
support the white knight maybe
retreating
and there we go both kings doing a bit
of a dance but maybe black has enough of
a counter play maybe he can start
pushing his pawns on the on the king's
sides like very fast
i think he should at some point i would
ideally want to put my pawns on light
squares and do do that so for example
black could maybe push his h pawn
forward two squares blockade on the
light squares and they use his bishop to
trade pawns
uh but okay he's actually trying to
sneak around a different way the black
bishops has gone back it wants to go to
the a5 square to the side of the board
and wants to sneak behind if you can
pick up that black bishop and put it
behind white's pawns on the diagonal on
the dark square diagonal all of white's
pawns are going to drop
so that's really really clever by eric
he's going to use his bishop to tie down
white's king and knight to the
protection of their kingside pawns
i don't think magnus is going to win
this anymore no it's a beautiful idea
from eric
really it's very key actually to
maintaining the
defensive possibilities alive
i agree with you david i just don't see
a way yeah i don't see a way forward we
have to show this because eric's found a
really really nice idea he's dropped his
bishop back it was on a great central
square but he's just trying to bring it
to the side of the board then in and
behind and look at all of white's pawns
they're just right for the picking all
of these pawns on dart squares if the
bishop does get behind it's just going
to be if anything winning for black so
white's king now has had to step back
but if the bishop just leaves itself on
this side of the board on this diagonal
hinting at later coming in then the
white king has to stay guarding this
square
the white knight has to stop the white
uh the black king coming in and
how can white make progress maybe you
can't you can't white is just completely
frozen this night stopping the black
king from coming forward and uh yeah it
just looks like an easy draw now for
eric i think we're finding an answer
which are better i earlier i said good
night against bad bishop this time it's
the opposite the bishop dominating the
white knight let's go back to the
players we might see a result
shortly
if eric can maybe hold his nerve and
also make sure he plays quickly enough
yes he plays with 10 seconds all the
time
yeah
as i was talking i looked at the clock
and
slightly panicked
10 seconds or 15 seconds every time eric
moves now i don't know why he uses so
much time he just needs to make a good
bishop move and uh he has a whole board
to make them so okay so he's just
centralizing the bishop okay so magnus
he's been sneaky you know
he's saying well maybe i'm going to do
something with my king on the right side
you push a pawn forward and eric says no
he's not going to go for that
lock it down really nice strategy just
pawns on the opposite color of your
bishop the black bishop controls dark
squares the pawns control the light
squares uh just one to remember at home
um the king coming back where he came
from
it had found no joy on this side of the
board uh magnus has all the time in the
world
eric doesn't have all the time in the
world two
seconds but uh yeah unfortunately still
nothing for eric
sorry no way for magnus come through and
not much to do for eric either he can
just sit and wait there we go the bishop
just kind of yo-yoing back and forth
between this square the center
and
magnus can't really break through if he
starts pushing pawns for example white
can push the f pawn forward he only
creates more weaknesses in his own camp
and magnus has to maintain this kind of
blockade this type of fortress with the
white knight and pawn and i think uh
it's going to shuffle the bishop between
those two squares and no but magnus is
going for it he's making a pawn break
okay so he is trying and as you
mentioned earlier you've got to play end
games out to the end right yes yes right
the final move to king versus king yeah
also he notices that his opponent is
playing not so fast let's say and only
with seconds on his clock so maybe he
will be able to surprise his opponent at
a certain point and then he can have
chances
yeah and uh okay a trade of pawns
magnus making you a bit of a face though
now black's bishop can come to the
center of the board white knight
actually has no squares at all
i think his plan is to trade also g bomb
yeah so magnus has only one plan he's
got to push his pawns forward
um literally nothing else to do he's a
dog with his bearing you know
but we know that all these trays are
good for the weak side right yeah
let's exchange all the bones and then
we're fine but even if you do exchange
the the pawns say so for instance black
holds the white king at bay so for
instance here you don't take pawns and
invite the king to step to the fourth
row you just hold the tension what is
eric going to do
what is magnus going to do sorry magnus
magnus has nothing to do um he just has
to wait
but then again okay i'm shocked by the
evaluation bar what is the idea behind
this one he's blocked things up
completely now eric has to just wait can
white somehow get the king back into the
game remember white's knight has no safe
squares you can't push your extra pawn
either
forward because then the black king
comes towards the white knight
okay the white king tries to get in it's
denied that's the check it's kicked back
i think it was one trick if if ferry
could move his bishop out of this
diagonal then knight could jump to c3
because e4 became a weakness
so actually there was an idea i think
that's the plan anyway because white's
king is just going to sidestep now to
the d2 square
white knight is going to step back and
as you mentioned black's central pawn is
actually isolated now
maybe king king moves to d2 and then he
supports the knight who will jump
to the square
to the only square c3 yeah so white's
knight is going to get back to the game
maybe eventually i don't think that's
going to change too much because as soon
as the white knight steps away the black
king will come down and pick off the
white sea pawn
but magnus is trying he's at least
trying to force eric down under 10
seconds again
that's when blunders might happen
yeah but intense game actually it is
quite tense especially because uh magnus
will be taking a decision eric will have
to be calculating at super speed in
order to see what's the best defense for
him and you know he's considering should
he put his bishop in the middle of the
board should he try to go for something
else and so he's gone for the king
move okay
wow okay so white might continue with
the plan but white's knight also has the
opportunity at some point now to try and
jump out of its cage from uh on the edge
of the board
it can jump forward i don't think that
really helps at the moment
uh that's the first move i would
calculate actually you know because it's
a consequence of black's last movie okay
he does it jump in with the knight and
uh if that knight starts um attacking
some pawns on the right they're gonna
fall actually maybe magnus has a route
to try and win a black central pawn i
was worried here about black's king
stepping forward in front of the white's
extra pawn oh there we go and now white
tonight can actually give a check
i don't think you want to go to any
other square you might get trapped or it
can step back actually wait it's
stepping towards the black horn maybe
magnus is winning suddenly yeah
wow we've seen a turnaround wow eric has
just let the white knight back into the
game
i played that move with less than one
second left
and he's losing his pawns those pawns
now the g black g6 pawn it's fallen yeah
and those pawns are way more important
than the pawns on the other side of the
board black's kings and just not
participating now it's in no man's land
and uh now he's got the best type of
pawn it's a protect it's a pass pawn and
the bishop he will win the bishop wow we
talked about squeezing water out of the
stone that has happened in this game it
was just a dead draw eric had it almost
within its uh within his grasp
and here we go black bishop has to stop
the white pawn but after this capture
that white pawn is going to cost black
his bishop and eric resigns magnus
squeezed out the win oh wow both players
shaking their heads a little bit of a
payback for magnus carlsen he lost in
the air things monsters in this one he
was able to win against eric hansen what